All right. Yael Shemer, thank you so much
for joining us on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you so much for having me Michael.
So, you're originally from Israel
but you live in New York.
And now you're visiting Israel.
Yeah. That's right. I'm here for a month,
but I moved to New York six months ago.
And you moved there
for your start of TULU. Right?
Yeah.
Okay. So, what is TULU?
Talk to me about TULU.
So, TULU is an on-demand rental service.
We provide smart rental units
in apartment buildings, in neighborhoods,
in offices
where tenants can practically download
our app and rent whatever they want
for as long as they want.
So, we work mainly in residential buildings
in Manhattan.
We also have 10 locations in Tel Aviv.
Some student dorms.
We're now launching a location with Wix
so employees can actually rent something
after work and return it the next day
or for the weekend.
But really our mission is to re-shape the way
people use and consume stuff.
Okay. So, it's the idea of renting stuff.
What stuff are we talking about?
Is this like, it's vacuum cleaners and bicycles?
Is that the sort of stuff we're talking about?
So, it's a wide range from what you really need,
and what you kind of want but don't need.
Which also makes sense to rent.
So, we have a Dyson vacuum cleaner,
and we have a ladder, and a drill,
and a projector, and a steamer.
So, the essential stuff for a home.
So, household items,
but we also have fun stuff
like a VR headset, a drone.
- Wow.
- Sewing machine.
And we just have a very eclectic,
So, we always have the essential product
that we know people are using
and then we also try pop-up products
and pasta maker, mixer, air fryer.
So Yael, one of the key things that
I think unifies all of these things together
is that all of them break.
Right? All of them are bound to break
at a ... point.
So, how does that even work?
So, you go to these apartment buildings.
I'm guessing you have a room
where you're putting in all of these supplies.
And then something breaks.
What do you do?
So, actually when our users break something,
we just ask them to tell us,
and then we'll repair it.
So, our philosophy is to really try
to repair everything we can
or to provide products that are higher quality.
And we know from our users also that
they rather use a really good projector
but they're buying a bad one from online
because they don't want to spend the money.
So, our stuff don't really break.
And if someone hurt it on purpose,
which almost never happens,
we kindly just take it
and take a deep breath
and understand that it's a part of
educating a market.
Right. So, okay.
So, Yael, educating a market,
talk to me a little bit about this
this idea and it's not very conventional.
This idea that you have an apartment building
and you have all the tenants share
the same Dyson vacuum cleaner.
So, where did this come from
and what are the different challenges
in educating the market for that?
So actually TULU is,
ever since we started TULU
my co-founder Yishai and I
and we have an amazing team
here in Israel and in New York,
people are telling us this is such a simple idea.
And it had to happen.
But what we’re doing that is different,
is we're providing access to a really
highly maintained household items.
We're choosing our products carefully,
and it's very aesthetic and it's a product.
It's something that really wants
to be a part of your lifestyle
and create a habit in your lifestyle.
So, starting from our design
and our data and our marketing,
everything, it's just like a brand
but in your building and
it's just like a gym or a pool.
It's an amenity you have.
Something you can use in your life in the building,
but also, now, as I told you,
we have other ideas regarding the workplace
and regarding neighborhoods
around sharing stuff.
But the sharing idea is not new like you said.
People tried doing peer to peer rentals.
And what we figure is that
the access economy is just,
just makes more sense. Yeah.
So, I mean the whole idea
of sharing goes back all the way
to the days of the Kibbutz, right?
When the inception of Israel and they said,
"Okay. Let's share a lawnmower
across the whole Kibbutz.
We don't need each person to buy their own"
But this also speaks pretty close to what
I believe WeWork started few years ago
called WeLive. Right?
And others have picked up on this idea
of shared living spaces
and the fact that the new generation
might be more open to the idea
of reducing privacy,
more sharing, more social interactions.
So, where does that fit in
to this whole genre and paradigm?
So, actually the meaning of TULU is
originated from TULU, which are
Chinese buildings in China.
It's a very very beautiful big structure
with micro-apartments that the center of,
it's a circular structure that the center of it
has the kitchen, the living room.
Of course, it doesn’t look like what we know.
But the idea is to really leverage
spaces in a building where the individual
doesn’t need to own or to have stuff
that can be shared with more people
and then therefore use space better.
So, my co-founder is an architect,
and I come from an environmental background.
And together we really,
we were really thinking hard about
how come cities,
people live so close to one another
and there are much progress happening
in the world of rentals and co-living
like you said
but there's still no integration
in your daily life.
If you really wanna do sharing,
you have to move to a WeLive
or you have to move to a,
kind of prestige living situation
where people living in buildings right now,
they can still do that.
So as you said, our demographic
is mostly young professionals.
People that are,
showed on research that are more adaptive,
and early adaptors to the idea of access.
And differently than a Kibbutz,
we're using an app,
and a state of mind
where, in a Kibbutz
if you borrowed something from someone
and they brought it back dirty,
you would get upset
and you would talk to them.
But now it's through us.
And we take care of everything.
And you pay us.
So, in a sense it's a bit easier on the user
to go through the mental process
of trusting a company to do that for you,
but we are trying to create
a sense of ownership in a rental world
where, if you took your vacuum cleaner,
you'd wanna return it clean
because you know your neighbors
are also relying on that.
Right. And I think
it does also speak to a difference on
I imagine living in an apartment building
and then my neighbor above my floor
comes and says, "Hey Michael,
can I borrow your vacuum cleaner?
Mine just broke."
I'd say, "Yeah, of course.
Here just grab it."
If somebody on the street
comes up and says to me,
"Hey Michael can I come up with you
to take your vacuum cleaner
and I'll bring it back."
Probably not so much. Right?
So, I think there is some psychological
acceptance in the fact that you're sharing
this living building or office with other people.
And automatically,
you have something in common
that you're more apt to share these
more personal things. Right?
Vacuum cleaners are going on all these
different surfaces. But how big does it get?
So, how many of these items
do you actually offer
to apartment buildings or offices?
Each TULU unit has around 25 products.
It really depends on the size of the building.
So, our average size is around 200 units.
And then we just decide how many Dyson,
how many scooters, how many printers,
how many -
200 units means 200 apartments
in a building?
Apartments in a building.
- Wow
And then our matrix as a company
is to really engage with as many people
as possible within a building
or within a neighborhood.
So, we also work with Tel Aviv Municipality
and we have this really cute
TULU room in the middle of
Nordau Boulevard where we install
the smart glass door. And it's 24/7.
And people can just come pick up
folded chairs, a tent, bike carrier,
sewing machine, different stuff.
And then we also calculate how many
potential users we can get.
And that's kinda how we think about it.
That's incredible.
And that is in Tel Aviv?
That's in Tel Aviv. We have three locations.
We have Tel Aviv, New York and New Jersey.
And hopefully in the upcoming year
we'll have some more surprises.
Incredible. So, what are the biggest challenges
approaching this type of new market?
You are creating a new market
in a sense. Right?
I mean, this is something that's very different,
and I imagine that there is a generation gap
on accepting this new customer behavior.
Is there?
There is a generation gap.
You know, we've discovered that our
product market fit
is actually in student dorms.
People that are temporary. The renters. They're also -
- I would love to use it in my dorm. Yeah.
Yeah, you know, and the average millennial
moves every three years.
So, if you're buying crap you don’t need
you also have to carry it with you
to the next apartment
because you're cheap. You're young.
You're a student.
You don’t wanna buy new stuff.
That's exactly my issue now.
I wanna come back to Israel for six months
with my girlfriend,
but I have all this crap from Stanford
that I don’t know where to put.
So, friends have graciously offered to host it,
but it sucks because this is stuff that I don’t need
it's probably gonna go bad
in six months sitting away.
I wish I could just let somebody else use it
and then come back and rent it out again
for my next year.
Of course. It makes perfect sense.
Yeah. So, it's really a state of mind
we're, as young professionals
or millennials, our lifestyle
are more dynamic. We're moving a lot.
We don’t wanna be attached to things.
Some people like myself, I'm a minimalist.
I really love the joy of not having stuff.
It really brings me joy.
But other people also find a practicality of it.
And I think, when we designed TULU
our mission was to say,
"If we create something
that's good enough, that's reliable,
that rents you a suitcase when you need it
and you can rely on it,
that's how we're going to start
educating a market"
So, that's really
The first stage of TULU was for us
to understand that the building,
we have to be in a good location
in the building. We have to be in the lobby.
We have to be in an accessible place in the building.
It can't just be the roof or the basement
for us to really engage with the tenants.
But also, to really learn about our demographic.
It's people who move a lot, work a lot,
the weekends are the strongest usually.
So, that's how you educate a market.
You have to really be obsessed with
integrating in their lifestyle.
Right. So, then what are you learning about
your customer behavior over this past time?
What are some of the things
that you've been observing?
Some stuff are easier to rent than others.
Some like bikes and scooters
and a vacuum cleaner, and some brands.
Those are easier right?
Yeah.
Okay.
What did you say?
Those are the easier kinds.
The bicycles and the vacuum cleaners.
Yeah 'cause it's already happening
and you really just don’t wanna buy
something that cost a thousand dollars.
And you really see the value for money.
We rent a couple dollars an hour.
And then some other stuff are just
a bit more challenging in how you tell
the story of renting them.
Whether if it's cooking products
or if it's more personal stuff
that are still rentable.
So, I think these are some of our challenges.
Really learning the curve
of getting enough products rented in a month.
Changing our inventory and making it
contextual to the life of our users.
If it's a PS5 that just is coming out,
you know we'll have it.
But also, being aligned with our mission,
which is to really always be
in the frontier of rentals.
And how do we make more people
be adapt to it and learn about it
and try it for the first time.
So, and what is the business model?
So people come, paint me a picture.
They come in to the room.
They open the app.
They see a PlayStation five.
Then what happens?
And then they add credit.
They can choose a plan.
And then they rent it for as long they want.
And they have a ticking clock.
You pay by the hour.
When you're done, we ask you how it went
and we get you to rent it again.
Okay. So, you self-report everything. Right?
We what?
You self-report everything?
Yeah.
Okay. That's very very cool.
And then, Yael, tell me a little bit
about your background.
So, you did quite a few projects
and you led quite a few organizations
prior to forming TULU.
So, where did you come from?
Well, I'm originally from Be'er Sheva.
Lehavim, which is the southern part of Israel.
I moved to North Carolina for my middle school
and high school.
When I moved back to Israel
I became a tour guide in the army.
It was like hiking for two years,
which is a, very privileged.
I fell in love -
- I think you did it right
yeah. I was fascinated with nature.
With everything that's happening
with climate,
and I decided to learn, to study
environmental science.
And in my bachelor’s degree,
I became an activist in the field of
environmental justice, transportation,
and then that's how I started learning
about food waste and also fashion waste
and consumption.
And these were I guess the seeds
but only when I was accepted into
a program at MIT
which is called Our Generation Speaks.
We were in designX accelerator for three month,
and that's how I met Yishai, my co-founder.
And it was a year when I was listening to podcasts
all the time about entrepreneurship,
but I never really thought
I would do something myself.
I really thought I would go to an NGO
kind of world and hopefully also become
maybe a politician.
Nothing was really set.
Wow. Quite a different path.
Yeah. But I think you can be an entrepreneur
in so many fields.
Just the tech world, it's where it's harvested.
But you can just, it's a mentality.
And when I met Yishai,
and he's coming from an architecture background
and my background,
things just kinda started to make sense.
And we said let's work together.
Let's create something together.
And we really started from
the problem we're trying to solve
and not from TULU.
TULU was just an evolution of other ideas
we've had and so we said,
"Okay, now we know what we are doing."
Interesting. I think that's amazing
because I think that really
a lot of entrepreneurs, they go on
the different path and say,
"I have this idea. I'm in love with it.
I think it's a great idea.
And now I'm gonna force myself
to understand that there's a problem
behind this idea"
But going through the approach of,
okay, well the world is changing.
People need to get stuff.
People don't wanna necessarily own the stuff.
It's expensive. It's cheap. It breaks.
There is a problem and now let's find
a solution to this problem.
That's exactly how I wanna approach and start.
And what are some of the sort of
earned secrets that you've learned
over the past few years running this thing
that perhaps you would go back and say
to your few years younger self?
Well, when we started the company,
I was still doing my environmental science
master’s degree.
And I was like, "Okay, I can do that
and that together. It's totally possible.
And I can also work"
And I think the minute I realized
that I have, besides committing to TULU,
being my full-time thing.
It's also a mentality.
You have to wake up and go to bed
thinking about something
that's really meaningful to you
and you have to commit to it.
So, I had to leave everything
and say okay it's scary.
It's really scary but I have to do it.
So, this is the first thing I learned
that I have to really prioritized
this and only that.
And when you build something,
you can have a really good idea
but it's about the team
and it's about the people you work with.
And being a co-founder,
or leading something,
I can work 24/7 but in order for other people
to be aligned with what we're doing,
you just have to create a sense of
togetherness
which is something we're working on.
Right.
And personally, moving to New York
for that, it's just,
it's so much fun to see the similarities
between Tel Aviv and New York
with millennials mainly.
Like we have such similar buyer personas.
Such similar people that are adapting
and reacting the same way to our product.
And I'm just fascinated with the world of rental
'cause I really believe that,
you know, going forward with everything
that's happening in the world,
and I'm not even talking about
the coronavirus.
I'm talking about the way we act as humans.
I really think solutions that are practical,
that are fun, that are sexy,
that are interesting,
these are the solutions that are
gonna carry people to be obsessed with
and to wanna use and to wanna pay for it.
And we decided to do it ourselves
rather than wait for someone else to do it.
I love it. So, where is this going?
So, now you have the challenge of,
okay, you have the product.
You found a product market fit in some areas.
How do you get this now
to millions of people?
Well, you know, raising some money.
But definitely we are much more
comfortable now with what we're offering
and we know where we're aiming
and we know what could possibly happen.
And of course, we've been getting a lot of offers
that are shifting us from our original idea.
But yeah. Now we just wanna scale.
We're ready to scale. Ready to expand.
We're ready for partnerships.
So, it's been a lot of fun.
We're fantasizing and also doing together.
So, it's a lot of fun.
And it's really fun mainly talking to our users
and learning what they need
and how it meets them.
You know, some people told us if
I knew I had a tool room in my building,
I would have come in a simpler way
to live in this building.
100%
But many times, we launch
after people already have their lease
and they already bought everything.
So, I think going forward it's gonna be easy for us -
... this is like the chicken and the egg now
because you're entering a market that
the apartments are already filled
and sort of you have to wait until the next cycle
of tenants to be able to validate
whether they really forego purchasing
the items and getting them for TULU.
But you know Yael, last thing that
I wanna mention is that you have a
pretty interesting way of entering this
than, you know most co-founders
they grew up entrepreneurial.
Went to study computer science or business,
and they grow up knowing that they
want to do a startup,
but it sounds like you didn't really know
you're going to do a startup.
Right a tour guide in the army.
Environmental science.
So, how is that process like for you?
I remember when I was a,
I had a different venture before TULU.
We were doing hydroponics on roofs
with a great friend.
And when I met him for the first time,
he told me, I was like "What do you do?"
And he said, "I'm an entrepreneur."
And it was for me like mind blowing.
What do you mean you're an entrepreneur?
It's a thing. I'm an entrepreneur.
And I went home
I googled entrepreneurship.
I had to learn about it.
I realized you can study it in university.
And that has just kind of sat with me.
And then I realized,
you know, if there is stuff or causes that
you really relate to and you wanna do
something about it,
entrepreneurship is a tool.
And of course, now I'm surrounded
with the tech world and I see people that
they know more about it than me sometimes.
But it doesn’t intimidate me.
It's just that this is, to create
an interesting startup
you can come from a very you know,
It's just that there's such a wide range.
That's it. There's some a wide range
and I love being there in this range
and having my own leash.
And I've been finding lots of pleasure
talking to other women
from an environmental field
interested in also doing something like that.
Yeah. Yeah. No
Yael, it's very very impressive and
it's very very inspiring.
Before we leave, I have to ask three words
that you would best use to describe yourself.
I'm daring
- Hardest question.
I think I'm daring.
I'm also simple.
And I'm very optimistic.
Daring, simple, and optimistic.
I like that combination.
Very very cool.
Yael, toda raba. Best of luck with TULU.
I hope that next year
when I'm back at Stanford,
you'll already be there.
I do too
We'll talk
And yeah, I look forward to
to maintaining this friendship.
Thank you very much.
Me too. Thank you so much for having me.
Bye bye.